you had a huge stunt where you were
suspended with hooks going through your
back I remember that well and I was like
I would have done it with hooks through
my butt cheeks or something I don't know
well you're crazier than me yeah I'm in
the world of Illusion even though I Had
No Illusion I had no painkillers no
numbers I hung for 6 hours I broke the
record when I first went up I felt like
I was going to puke why were you ready
to throw up on there cuz of the pain
when your skin separates from your
muscle basically like when you pick up a
cat by the neck that's kind of how
you're hanging all of the weight of
everything internally is just like
stretched it's just insanely painful but
you you have done things without really
a lot of planning had something to drink
and Bam ended up in a hospital so many
times what was the mental state my need
for attention outweighs my need for
safety and comfort